let me tell you something else Larry I
got this Norman thing's cursing through
my vein Richard Lewis you have been
inspired by Josh Norman yes and also I
know I heard about the Pitino thing I
did a movie few people have seen it
mmm there's the midway through to the
end it's the best work I've ever done
it's called game day and I play a
college coach in the finals do you
really and I it's it's you can get its
get a ball it's called game day in the
last half of the movie is the best
acting I've ever done and I and I just
did 49 slick my hair back huh and it was
I mean I don't want to say that the
character was pretty dark and I know
he's had some checkered stuff in his
life but this guy really is screwed up
is that right cuz I'm a great coach in
my head and boy my locker room talks any
actors out there who want any kind of
help just get game day anyway where were
we season 9 of Curb Your Enthusiasm
premieres Sunday night on rock'n'roll
and it's great to see you here Richard
Lewis in person in the flesh are you
playing yourself on curb are you doing a
is Larry the other day we had dinner for
the first time since Eisenhower
administration no we had dinner and I
said I said you know people always ask
you they say is that really you he said
no I would like to be more like this
more confrontational Larry yes he's not
a confrontational guy at all in real
life no right he doesn't you know he
doesn't suffer fools gladly and he's a
man you know and he and he doesn't lead
I mean he's he's somewhat of a Larry on
the show but he's not you know he's not
as annoying as that Larry David what
about you in the show I asked him mister
that question he says well you're you
but you're worse he says I'm worse
because I put you in these heightened
situations
I mean I'm pissed off because my
parakeet died and he says me a text I
would eat it but I would be I'm a very
sense see I wear my heart on my sleeve
the only reason I did stand-up I've done
it for 49 years 49 years this is up I
just turned 70 and I'm and I'm going on
the road and I'll be at the Roxy in LA
finally for the first time
yeah in December and I'm playing Philly
and karolides yeah you and Artie lying
you're gonna be in Florida we've got to
recovering drug addicts I just saw on
the board and in Reno that one of us
won't make our last punchline nowhere
he's doing fine and I've been doing I've
been sober a long time so I love the guy
right God just pray for the cat you know
and no but he's just too hard man I mean
we had dinner once we went out for
dinner yeah he calls me up and he said I
said what time you called me up in the
afternoon he says let's have dinner I'll
meet you there now it's always now just
like some diva actress and I said what
do you know come on right now he says
let's have dinner so I just had a hero
sandwich he said I'll meet you at 401
401 there's a mental case is like Rain
Man
so I said 401 I said then we were on the
phone for an hour I said we got up to
518 I said all right and it was his
high-profile thing and we're on Rodeo
Drive but one of those streets in
Beverly Hills and you said he goes to
let these a regular guy buddy he's Larry
David over every wife so cannot for that
matter so I got there an hour early to
pay the check I said to make a mr. Lewis
how are you - call me Richard but listen
I'm paying for dinner it's a Chinese
restaurant and he says probably mr. Chow
is probably okay a restaurant I said and
he said oh no you can't pay I can't pay
I can't remem is the david obie up sorry
I don't care about me then I did my nine
what I mean I don't care about her can't
follow me I can follow him he can't
follow me I can catch him I get so he
said no we won't allow it I don't mean
to warn a lot was a screaming match this
sounds like it occur by the way yes and
I said take my credit card so I sit down
Larry comes an hour late after this our
phone for 16 503 518 was that gonna a
Jewish Airport controller out of control
so he gets there and I said Larry why
don't we make believe it's 1972 and
we're broke and we're all we care about
is comedy and and
and you know and just our passion for
our craft and whatever and he's and he
says what do you mean I wanted me one of
me we used to go to a Chinese restaurant
cheap I'd get soup we'd split it I'd get
money what beef all right I'll get the
shrimp
all right don't take too much of my
shrimp that will split it it was like
five hours okay he says we're not gonna
split anything here you come why not
you'll hurt the feelings of the chef I
said I couldn't care less about the chef
I just I'm hungry he says I know him
he's a personal friend I went you know
and now I'm worried about the check okay
the chef comes out with 18 entrees from
a turntable bigger net we should have
sent it to the army into the Navy to the
Marines and all and to a third-world
country we don't even have a discussion
rich the phone rings Steve Martin
Canadian of course and he doesn't say
goodbye he gets up he goes I forgot I
have put spoke a night and he leaves and
he leaves me with a hundred thousand
dollar bill with this Chinese food that
I couldn't even recognize it looked like
a peacock smoking a joint I didn't even
know what it was this is an episode of
Curb Your Enthusiasm I hope you realize
that that's like straight out of what we
would Mike might see honor he wants love
me he before I had a birthday I wanted
to give him a birthday present he loves
the Yankees I gave I bought two rare
Mickey Mantle cufflinks hmm and another
Yankee memorabilia and I said like I
don't owe him a letter how much he's
meant to man you know we were born in
the same hospital three days apart is
that right yeah this and it gets harder
than that we knew each other when we
were teenagers and hated each other we
never saw each other until we became
comedians and we didn't know we were the
same people 12 years before and we
almost had a well he doesn't think we
had a fistfight but I was ready to knock
him down so so I give them the gifts I
don't I don't want to be the table while
you're reading this letter it I it to
like love too much love yeah so I said
let me go to the bathroom read the
letter I want you to know what you mean
to me so you Richard Lewis went to the
bathroom well he'd come back
this letter he's already up leaving the
restaurant saying I gotta go I go we
haven't had it been an order yet it's
just my meat is running out now I'm not
suggesting he's I don't I know he's
wealthy but you know but when you have
that kind of money and his meat is
running out the guy should be
institutionalized and I'm allegedly one
of his best friends the whole thing
sucks
I love his daughters IATA I worship his
daughters yeah he's a he's the he's who
did I'm sorry I have a little bit of a
head cold who then one of the greatest
sitcom guys in the 70s all the families
yeah he's only in the last 40 years no
one can touch Larry David he's one of
the greatest storytellers ever maybe
well and again it just a terrific
performer herb is as good as it's ever
been and it's coming back on Sunday and
you know you mentioned how Larry was at
he's a big Yankee fan people noticed him
sitting right behind home plate and the
game where Judy red sweater nice sweater
yeah you look like Perry Como in Vegas
he said he sat there behind home plate
for the the game wearin judge hit home
runs now I know he's such a Yankee freak
I know sees he's fired about them and he
loves his Jets and he loves his Nick
what about you well no I screwed up all
my friends shaving my sports my I was I
was a I am a big sports fan but I was a
little boy when when the Dodgers were
there and sir when I was six or seven
they moved and I was shaken I was to the
core and then the Giants well I was I
was a Brooklyn Dodger fanatic and you
know and I was raised to Vince soon as I
came out of the womb fasten your seat
belts good impression of physically that
could have been telling Cevallos I'm
sorry that's the worst
Richard good stuff get Roy Firestone get
Roy Firestone for an impression so he
does great impression so at any rate I I
moved to LA in the 70s
yeah I heard Vinny again thank God yeah
I wrote a book once with an essay how
important it was because he was
throughout all our lives
all our lives you know all these
generations but then I said wait a
minute
and this is what turned it around the 78
Yankees went in with 14 and a half games
behind and he came back Bucky Dent all
those guys right and I and I just fell
in love with that team and I said wait a
minute I can't I have to root for my New
York team so now I'm you know I was a
jet in a met fan now I'm I'm Korean New
York Korean ping-pong team do you know
the pandas there's a great player Fong
Lee he has a great defensive end he has
great backhand there unfortunately the
worse than the 1962 Mets they're two and
a hundred and eleven but I root for them
because you're true-blue
and you can get him on satellite on ping
pong Channel yeah at the Richard Lewis
on Twitter check out Richard Lewis
online.com to see when the tracks that
my fears tour dates comes through your
town you with Artie Lange in Coconut
Creek Florida I'm a seventh than you're
in Caroline's in New York City the week
after that all the gigs after that but
come see me in LA first time in five
years at the Roxy December 9th with a
very special guest very good Richard you
are a special guest on this show
Congrats on another season of curb yeah
you're rockin babe thanks man you bet
back in 60 seconds and I'll tell you
something else Larry my parakeets were
important in yo the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to